and dude you look great [ __ ] 62 years
old thank you steve yeah believe this
yeah man look fantastic oh man i bought
him 59.
you know what i'm saying and i ain't
gonna lie but you know i um
got myself clean and sober now i've been
been um
i've been off drugs hard drugs and [ __ ]
for like 12 years
now you know for the cokes and all of
that stuff you know that was like 12
years ago
but you know um i've been still drinking
and i was
my hennessy smoking my cigarettes
so now
it's been about a year since i've lit a
cigarette
it's been about 10 months now since i've
drank alcohol
and
not only that but my birthday that just
passed this mark this past march 16th is
the first sober birthday i've spent
since i was maybe eight years old wow
yeah so it feels good it feels good
there you know what i'm saying to be
sober man and not only that but my
business life
has gotten a lot more better now you're
saying that on your podcast
since you put down yes i put down the
alcohol and the cigarettes that's good
you know what i'm saying my business
i remember hearing you had a bunch of
chicken restaurants yeah well i had four
honestly i had four
and i ain't going to lie but my chicken
is so slamming
i've had people come up to me
and say play this is the best chicken i
ever ate
and the reason why that these
restaurants aren't up now is because of
the management they didn't do the right
thing and they didn't run the business
right
okay so if you run your business right
your business will stay successful you
don't run it right then it's going to
fail
so at least that i can
feel proud to say that my businesses
failed because of bad management not bad
food good
did i read that right that you went to
culinary school i sure did i went to
culinary school in 1978
and i got me a cooking degree
and when i went to school i learned how
to do institutional cooking which is
like baking pans of fettuccine alfredo
rice pilaf for like three and four
hundred people at one time wow suzettes
oh man yeah i learned how to do it all
fruit soups peanut butter soup
i mean
i i did it all man you still cooked to
this day i sure do and my specialty
right now is
like we were just saying fried chicken
chicken yeah yeah because that's gonna
be my franchise you know and i and i had
a vision that one day all of my ffcs are
going to supersede kfc's and i'm not
in competition with kfc's flavors fried
chicken fried chicken
fried chicken flavored fried chicken you
know and i'm not in competition with the
colonel i'm in competition with myself i
just want to outdo me it's called
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole and
if you go on amazon and type in stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on amazon and buy stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude